most of the people are vegan
right now
in the way they in the way that they
think i mean almost that all the people
wouldn't want to kill the animal
themselves or
watch how the animal is how they kill
animals for their their food
but there's still a big
but there's still a big barrier between
what we eat and what we see on the plate
and what happens to the animals so the
only thing is to you know to to connect
the dots between what we eat and what
happens with animals but already now
most of the people are vegan and they're
the way they think
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
we all know that veganism is a growing
trend but it's time to talk
strategically about it and who's better
than omripos the founder and ceo of
vegan friendly umri has a law degree
from the hebrew university of jerusalem
in 2012 he founded vegan friendly which
is the leading vegan organization in
israel since it was established
vegan-friendly launched many campaigns
that reached millions of people
including the biggest animal rights
march in history massive billboards
vegan add-ons a prime time and 10
million lecture welcome
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
fine great thank you for having me
thank you very much for coming
you're one of the leading figures in the
israeli vegan scene running an
organization called vegan friendly
i don't believe i've had a vegan
advocate yet on the show we've done
almost a more more than 500 episodes and
i'm really excited to talk about a trend
that i have zero doubt that is going to
take over the world sooner rather than
later and i've been thinking a lot about
what's going to impact the the pace at
which it'll impact the world and i'm
excited to pick your brain on your
experience and what you're doing within
the israeli scene so
tell me a little bit about yourself and
how do you get into the vegan scene in a
leadership position
cool so um
basically um everything started when i
was uh 29
i was in my third year in law school in
the hebrew university
i was exposed to a graphic video of what
happens in the factory farming
and that changed my whole world at the
same time and became vegan and decided
to be also uh an activist i didn't
exactly know what to do but i was very
determined to
do whatever i can
establish vegan friendly 2012
and since then what we're doing in the
organization is trying on one hand to
make veganism accessible as much as
possible for people to become
for them to be for it to be easy for
them to become vegan and also raise
awareness to what goes on in factory
farming
and the organization originally was
relatively small it was basically only
me
the first four years now we have over 30
people
on staff and we also expanded to
to you the uk last year we have there a
team of four people and next year we'll
probably expand to
the states
wow and so
before we talk specifically about vegan
friendly
give me a little bit of an overview
about
you know veganism in general i think
it's still important but also where we
are in terms of the trend today both in
israel and
globally cool so basically when people
say veganism they can think about lots
of different things but for me though
what it means is
not
hurting exploiting killing animals when
we don't have to do it
it has an amazing benefit obviously for
the animals an amazing benefit for the
planet and also for our health
and that's one thing second thing is
up until 2012
veganism almost didn't exist at all in
israel israel was one of the most
unvegan countries in the world it has
less than one percent of vegans
and now israel is the most vegan country
in the world we have over five percent
wow 400
increase in just a couple of years
and yeah and if you look at the vegan
category in the supermarkets it exploded
every year between 10 to 30 percent
increase every year from 2012 2020. so
that's the biggest growing category in
the supermarket
for almost a decade now
now why why is this why did we why do we
see such a huge surge in veganism
specifically also in israel
yeah so a couple of reasons uh what
started everything was a lecture of
gary yourofsky it's called the best
lecture that you'll ever see if you want
to check it out in youtube and it got
like almost about 2 million views in
just one year and
we believe that
they created about 100 000 vegans in
just in a short period of time so that
kind of like kick-started it and also
because israel is a is a small country
then if you have a hundred thousand
people that's a percent of the
population so it's not like in the
states
that in order to
to increase the percentage you need to
get millions of people on board yeah
that's one thing second thing is that
israel is a
very small country and things
travels really fast especially through
social media
at the time israel was one of the
countries that they used facebook the
most in the whole world i think the
average was about
four hours a day
and when this when the the activists and
organizations started spreading viral
videos about what what goes on factory
farming the nasa people decided to ditch
uh eating an animal protein and
yeah and that
spread the the the message really really
fast enough also i think we have a
mentality
of people that are not afraid to to say
whatever they think
even to people that they don't even know
at all in the
supermarket and also it's relatively
easier to find vegan food in israel
because of the mediterranean
diet and also because of the culture
a culture here
so
so the beginning the beginning point was
was relatively easy for people to get on
board and become vegan even though as i
mentioned in 2012 almost nobody was
vegan in israel right and so you know
obviously there's a lot of
i wouldn't say controversy there's a lot
of different conversations that are
happening around meat eating in general
some with with credible scientific
information
a lot of it without and and and like i
mentioned in the beginning i i have no
doubt that the world will become vegan
altogether i i personally believe that
there's going to be a lot of
there's going to need to be a lot of
economic and technological incentives
that will push that forward from your
perspective
leading
this organization and understanding
strategically where we're headed
what do you think needs to happen
in order for the world as a world not as
a small population but as the entire
population to make this big shift
well i think that i don't know if the
i mean there are a couple of options one
option is that it will continue to grow
gradually until get to this critical
mass point between
which we believe is about between 10 and
15 of the population and there are
studies that show that the
social change occurs
very fast and once you you pass a
tipping point which as i mentioned is
about
10 to 50 the population
and so that's one option the second
option is that we'll get a situation
that's so bad with uh probably will be
through the the climate change
that this is that things will be will be
so bad that the countries will have to
uh address this issue very seriously and
start passing laws
another option is the technology
obviously if all of a sudden you have a
lab meet or really advanced technology
that allows you to have
really a good
vegan options even it's even if it's
from a plant base and it becomes also
very very cheap
then that's something that can
accelerate the
the
the practice of people eating
plant-based and not the
animal protein so there are a few things
that can happen and there's a good
chance that they'll all happen in this
in the same time
and
so yeah so i mean
basically most of the people are vegan
right now
in the way they in the way that they
think i mean almost that all the people
wouldn't want to kill the animal
themselves or
watch how the animal is how they kill
animals for their food
but there's still a big
but there's still a big barrier between
what we eat and what we see on the plate
and what happens to the animals so the
only thing is to you know to to connect
the dots between what we eat and what
happens with animals but already now
most of the people are vegan and they're
the way they think and their
moral
aspect and so i think that you're
touching on a really interesting point
you're saying that you know in essence
as human beings you know ethically and
morally we are thinking vegan yet our
consumer behavior which a lot of it is
also shaped through media advertisements
through social expectations through
economic incentives that's the part
where there is this this connection and
what you're actually saying is that you
know we actually need to go to to to to
have a world which allows us to
just take our consciousness and take our
ethics and morals and just translate it
into our daily life right
yeah
exactly
and i think that i think that's really
interesting because i'm thinking a lot
about it from a strategic economic
perspective
when you're talking about you know the
human body or you know the lifestyle
that we have what what do we know today
about
alternatives to meet the the need for me
to the lack of need for meat obviously
there's a lot of conversation about it
yeah well for me the most important uh
point is that the humans don't have to
eat meat to be healthy they can be
healthy eating plant-based a plant-based
diet and as soon as you understand that
point which is the the most important
point then you understand that eating
meat is a choice it's a choice that you
make that you can eat meat and you also
can decide not to eat meat so it's not
something that you have to do
in order to be healthy and and once you
understand that i mean if i had if if if
a plant-based diet would make me will
make me sick then there's a good chance
i wouldn't be vegan but since i don't
have to do it then i choose
to buy and consume products that don't
cause suffering and destroy the planet
when i can choose something that doesn't
so for me it's that simple right
now vegan friendly as a movement so you
you studied large hebrew university and
you decided to dedicate the last nine
years or so to this great movement
what is your sort of strategy within
israel to go and expand it you're
creating viral campaigns you have so
many people working with you um on this
on this great mission what is what is
your strategy as a leader as you're
pushing forward this trend
yeah well um as i mentioned the
beginning we have two
two aspects that we that we concentrate
on one is making veganism accessible
which that's basically the how how to
become vegan how to stay vegan and
obviously you know our certification on
products and businesses we have huge
events like we had we had a
vegan fest 2019 about 50 000 people came
to the event and this year was supposed
to have about a hundred thousand people
and unless the corona jumps in and
destroys another event and
and on the other hand we
try to work on raising awareness through
the campaigns just like the 10 million
lecture that we just launched last month
and a tv ad that i'm sure that you've
heard of x refresh
and so and those and so and that's a
raising awareness that's the why why
should i
taste the
plant-based hamburger when i have the
real hamburger in front of me and we
believe as a strategy that we need to
work on the bowl and both of them at the
same time because if we only work on and
expanding the the vegan options
but we don't have any demand then you
know nobody will buy it and it will get
get off the menu and on the other hand
if you only work on raising awareness
and we have lots of people wanting to
become vegan but they don't want to have
any options that will also be very
difficult for them and that also won't
work so we believe that we need to work
on both of the of the things at the same
time simultaneously
and we also believe that in order to
even though we're a non-profit
organization we try to try to think as a
company or as a a startup high tech and
in a way that we try to build
win-win business models that will
benefit everybody so for example
uh if i was a non-profit organization in
the states for example because i know
that they do it and i'm going to add
vegan options i'll probably go to a
donor and tell them
i want to
add a hundred vegan options in a couple
of restaurants
and once i would like for you to donate
a certain amount of money and then of
the year i go back to the donor and show
him all the amazing stuff that we that
we've done and each year asked for him
again for uh resources to to continue
our project but when we're doing vegan
friendly try to think of a symbolic sum
that the businesses will pay the
organization
in which we in exchange will advertise
that they have vegan options
and
and then everybody benefits the
businesses the businesses get new new
customers we get money to sustain a
project and obviously the vegans enjoy
not they enjoy the project because they
know about more vegan options and they
have more vegan options and and then
obviously more people can can they
consume vegan options and unless animal
protein
products so that's an example of a
win-win
uh ecosystem that we created which
doesn't usually happen in non-profit
organizations
and we we do the same thing with also
with other projects for in the events we
have sponsors and vendors is certifying
products the same idea and even in the
donations by the way usually usually
organizations when they want to have
donations from from
followers they just tell them okay
please donate money and we'll do really
good things with the money and in vegan
friendly what we did is we established
this
concept that's called vegan active
the way it works is we encourage vegans
to donate a monthly donation their
donation goes directly to a campaign
that they believe in so they can choose
where their money goes to
and exchange they get benefits and
discounts and almost all the businesses
that we certify is vegan friendly so
they can donate 10 15 20 a month
and actually save
more money than what they donate and
this concept was extremely successful we
have now more than 6 000 donors that
donate directly to a life-changing
project and
do you see a shift as you're talking to
a lot of the organizations that are
producing these products uh for profit
obviously
is there a shift in the conversation
their willingness to consider they're
willing that they're they're maybe
starting to to think about it themselves
or is it still more in the shift of the
consumer that is becoming more conscious
yeah so it's interesting that 2012 the
demand was much much higher than the
supply and with time
especially the big companies launched
more and more vegan products and mostly
vegan cheese and vegan meat and and in
tofu
and and now we're seeing that especially
as as i mentioned the big the big
companies
are spending
much bigger
a much bigger budget on the launching
vegan products especially like nouveau
nestle universe
diplomat
also importing lots of vegan products
abroad and that's mostly because
their profit and the vegan products is
so much higher
than what they're getting from the
animal products so for example take a
milk a carton of milk
i think that they they they profit
between five to ten times more on a
carton of soy milk really
than cows yeah because think about it
their
profit is maybe three to four percent
unbelievable because all the things that
they need to do and they have the cow
and they have them and the antibiotics
that they need to put in and feed the
cow and so
the whole thing and with the soy milk
what do you have in us in an apartment
you have 92 percent water you have seven
percent of soy which is extremely cheap
and salt and maybe a couple more
ingredients but that's it basically and
they're also enjoying the fact that at
the moment
the vegan population is a stronger
financially a stronger uh
so they can also charge a higher a
higher amount
so yeah so it's much more profitable for
them and
there are a couple of years where the
they made money in the it's in the dairy
category because of the plant-based
cheese and milk not because of the
regular cheese and milk so everybody
knows it's going towards there and we
also have a really strong connection
with those companies and we talk to them
on a weekly basis and i mean they know
that the future is is going there it's
already there and so now at the moment
it's kind of like a race of what company
can
can launch more vegan products and it's
amazing to see i mean i never dreamed
five six seven years ago that i'll see a
commercials and television promoting
vegan products from nouveau and from
straus and then yesterday
billboards bus stations it's all over
and that's something that wasn't up
until two or three years ago well i
think a lot of this thanks to you and so
it it for me it's really interesting to
see to see the trend and
and i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm moving towards
that trend as well now i have a few last
questions not about veganism but more
about you before i let you go i know
that you have a few more interviews to
do take me back to your childhood and
before law school and what what really
fascinates you as a kid what really
drives your curiosity yeah i think i was
obsessed growing up and like um
with what's right and what's not right
like it's like like
fighting finding justice and and that's
something i think that
that hit base when i when i was exposed
to factory reforming the the biggest
unjustice thing that can happen in the
world killing 150 billion animals
destroying the planet or health so
that's something as a child that
definitely
resonated with me becoming vegan and
establishing vegan friendly
right and uh
what inspires you today so as you go
about your day today
a couple of things first of all my team
i see amazing people that
would wake up every morning and just
give everything they have and just
sometimes i look look at them from the
side and i think myself what amazing
people and so they inspire me and also
i still watch graphic videos of what
goes on in factory farming
reminding myself
every day the suffering that animals go
through
and
and also
on a personal note i
i would like to be one of the people
that could make a change in this world i
mean this is something that i've worked
really hard and for the last 10 12 years
and but to do a good change in the world
you know not a capitalist change so i'm
still working really hard to get there
to be somebody that can make a
difference
i love it
and the last question only three words
you would use to describe yourself
persistent
stubborn and
something that works really really hard
i guess
thank you for the great work that you're
doing it's an important mission we're
heading there and you're helping support
it so thank you very very much stay safe
and stay healthy thank you thank you for
having me of course